all right we are now live for the
April 2023 AMA that's ask me anything
session I've just gotten back from fast
walking about a mile and a half to get
back from visiting some cats here in the
east side of Milwaukee I'm here in the
downtown
and uh it was a lot of fun but I got my
arms scratched up a bit as you can see
we've already got some good questions
lined up so let me uh jump in and take
some of these so useless project what
would be your criticism of stoicism
slash stoic so first of all I would
criticize not capitalizing stoicism
because today we make a distinction
between lowercase s stoicism the
disposition or the pop culture thing you
know associated with people who aren't
really stoics but present themselves as
such and then actual ancient stoicism
with a capital S the philosophy so I can
say something about both I mean I think
that there's a lot of people who jumped
on the interest in stoicism jumped on
the bandwagon so to speak but really
don't know an awful lot about stoicism
and some of the things that they
actually say not only show they don't
understand the philosophy but are
actually at odds with it so you know all
of these people in Silicon Valley and in
the manosphere and productivity stuff
trying to harness stoicism for all their
little agendas I would say that's not
really stoicism right
um and you know insofar as they're
presenting it as if it is they're
they're lying which goes against the
virtue of Justice which would say that
truth is something important to uh to
protect and preserve and promulgate now
when it comes to like the actual
philosophy of stoicism
I'm you know I'm an Eclectic but I draw
pretty heavily on stoicism
I don't find
um
I don't find an awful lot of interest or
value other than sort of an antiquarian
way with their cosmology because their
physics you know is largely outmoded at
this point I don't think that the
universe is one vast rationally held
together a structure of causes and
effects and a rational being that
providentially organizes itself and us
and all that sort of things and and I
think the stoics
um like a lot of ancient philosophers
they made a very hard distinction
between us as rational animals and then
the other animals and I'm thinking those
boundaries with what we know about
animal behavior at least for certain
higher animals maybe breaking down
um I don't agree with the stoic position
that virtue and vice are sort of like an
on off switch you're either virtuous or
your vicious and there's like nothing in
between and you know somehow you go from
one to the other I think that's kind of
a non-starter I've actually done
a uh a whole talk about that that you
can find a video for last fall
um about stoic conceptions of virtue and
um you know I I don't agree with all of
their views on the emotions uh for
example I think that some of the things
that they thought were always bad
emotions aren't so but we do have to be
careful with them for example grief you
know I think that grief may actually
serve a valuable purpose for us so those
are some places where I'm at odds you
could say with the the stoics
um classical ones
uh James says you've often talked about
all the bad representations of
philosophical ideas from celebrities or
popularizers those in pop culture are
there any that you think do a good job
of representing them
um
I mean yes but they tend to be people
who actually know their stuff so you
know we could say for example thinking
about stoicism
you know who are good popularizers who
aren't going to steer you wrong you know
some of my colleagues like Massimo
pigliucci and Donald Robertson right but
those are people that also really know
their proverbial crap right they're not
they're not just popularizers or kind of
you know big picture broad Strokes kind
of thinkers who get some stuff writing
some stuff wrong
so I don't find an awful lot of value in
any of the people who are just pure
popularizers or just shooting for a
large audience but I don't spend a lot
of time looking at their stuff because
why would I waste my time on those
people unless I'm like doing a book
review or something when I could be
spending it actually reading the
philosophy that I rarely get enough time
to to read you know there's only 24
hours in a day
so I'm I'm not really a good person to
give you recommendations about that sort
of thing
here's another interesting one by and
Olivia I was wondering what your
thoughts are on Hannah Iran's reading of
Augustine
so rent is one of those philosophers
who's very interesting to read and often
off base but you know has some
interesting things to put in front of us
to think about
and you know so if you're thinking about
the life of the Mind where you know the
focus is on the will and the second part
you know this this idea that Augustine
invented or discovered the will I think
that those of us who work in ancient and
early medieval philosophy at this point
can say wow that is totally wrong you
know Augustine May intensify our study
of it but there's so many other earlier
Christian thinkers who are focusing on
the will and it's clearly you know
they're like something like it in
Epictetus and possibly even in Seneca
and Cicero
um so you know sometimes for
declarations about Augustine are a
little bit
they're reflective of not having read
enough other stuff from that era besides
Augustine right
um I mean I think she has interesting
things to say about Augustine and the
will and what Augustine has to reveal to
us about that and you know his
conception of memory and time and
things like that but I would I would
always be careful with a rent when it
comes to her her take on previous
philosophical thinkers
like a lot of people in her time and
really extending backwards a couple
centuries I would say she tends to be a
little bit too
uh sweeping and her generalizations
about stuff
here's an interesting one from snoot
best ways to get into darita and
deconstruction so the first thing you
got to realize
is that people are using the term
deconstruction today in ways very very
different than what diridian
deconstruction is diridian
deconstruction is in essence reading a
body of work against itself you know
bringing out the parts of it where it
you know kind of contradicts itself and
trying to think past that try to uncover
what has been you know covered up undo
binary dualities without getting rid of
them all together you know so it's a a
pretty rigorous method of working at
things at least in his early works I
mean in his middle Works he gets a
little
it gets a little bit loosey-goosey and I
would say sloppy with it but then you
know towards the end of his life with
books like the gift of death and
inspectors of marks and politics of
friendship he's he's becoming a bit more
rigorous again
and I think if you want to really read
darita you should begin with his early
works and so there's three that I
actually recommend
um one of them is his uh his piece on
horse roll and phenomenology called
speech and phenomena where interestingly
enough I wrote a master's thesis where I
ended up covering a lot of the same
ground bringing in distal sir to talk
about Linguistics and language and stuff
like that
um but it's it's good rigorous work that
he's doing there and then you know one
of his early Magnum what would be uh his
early magnum opus on grammatology good
stuff you know uh very interesting
challenging to read uh but I would say
worth the the work that it takes
and then
um you know a speech and difference a
writing and different sorry uh
got so caught up between speech and
writing writing and difference these
essays that he he writes and then you
know if you wanted to go on with stuff
after that you know he's got this middle
period where he's doing all sorts of fun
crazy stuff but I I think I'm a whole
with a few exceptions there's really not
an awful lot of Great Value there
um and then we have to kind of wait for
his
turn back to politics and religion in
the
1990s to find the really great stuff
towards the end of his his life so
that's what I I would say
um I mean if you're also asking about
like what secondary sources should I
read I'm not a great secondary sources
person because I don't spend a lot of
time
you know
um
reading other people's secondary sources
I create secondary sources myself but
I don't have an awful lot of time to to
review other people's things unless I'm
like writing an article or something
all right uh Galen says
um
as both a philosopher and a Catholic
what do you think of Pope John Paul II
encyclical fetus at razio
well I when I wrote my dissertation on
Maurice Blondell I actually sort of
bookended the uh discussion by saying we
begin with the pascendi dominicus gregas
you know against modernism of Pius the
10th and we basically end with fide
razio of John Paul II which by the way
if yakra long has pointed out in a great
article that
Maurice blondel isn't mentioned at all
in the document and that's because the
whole document is basically blown daily
in its its structure and approach
and you know Carol votiva or John Paul
II really knew his stuff he was a
philosopher himself from the Lublin
School of Thomas which meant that he you
know knew his his
basic uh Thomas Aquinas we could call it
genealogy but he also like knew a lot of
phenomenology and philosophy of action
like you know Maurice Blondell or
Gabriel Marcel or people like that so I
think it's a I think it's a great
document
um and it was very important I remember
when it came out you know hearing the
news in while I was in graduate school
in a philosophy department when all of
us being like oh wow we're gonna have to
see what what's actually going on with
this this this sounds quite interesting
right so you know I'm I'm a fan if you
actually look online and you type in
Greg or Gregory Sadler fide razio you're
going to see documents coming up because
it is it is a document that I myself
have written about and presented on at
uh different times
um you know in in uh different places so
yeah
um
all right Sean says do you think there's
any distinction between Christian
philosophy and Christian theology I
think there's uh lots of distinctions
but none of them are agreed upon by a
consensus so you can make whatever
distinctions you want
um one of the key things whenever you're
making a distinction like that is you
have to ask yourself
where are you making that distinction
from are you within a particular
tradition of understanding what
Christianity means you know uh maybe you
see things in ways different than other
Christians do uh historically or
ecumenically
um you got to be very very careful about
making pronouncements about you know
here is the dividing line between
Christian philosophy and Christian
Theology
and to bring up Maurice Blondell you
know he says well we can make that
distinction but it's really more like
gases that permeate each other right so
you got to ask yourself whenever you see
somebody making that distinction what
are they trying to do when with making
that distinction and are they making
that as a philosopher from the side of
philosophy like sketching out what the
boundary is from over here are they
doing it as a theologian or are they
doing it as something that straddles
both you know um
uh when trying to determine whether
ansum is a philosopher or a theologian
will actually say I don't think he
actually fits into either nicely it's
more like Christian canosis like Clement
of Alexandria right so
I'm I'm pretty you know I I understand
why people make these distinctions but I
think that we need to realize that
they're always
pragmatic rather than essential
distinctions right
uh Lucian confusion what's the best
argument for the existence of God do you
believe in God there's no best argument
for the existence of God I mean best in
this sort of case is a relative term
best for who best for what you know what
you got to ask yourself what is the
purpose of having Arguments for the
existence of God and there isn't even
you know full agreement in philosophy
about that Hegel for example for example
thinks that
um Arguments for the existence of God
are not supposed to prove in a
conclusive sense anything but rather be
paths that lead us to understanding what
the Divine is that already is out there
and what our relationship to it is other
people sort of on a different extreme
think that it's you know we have to have
these iron-clad knocked down drag out
arguments that will convince anybody you
know from any time whatsoever provided
they are a rational being and you know
that's a different approach let's say
um you know and I don't I don't think
that there is a single fast and I also
don't think that Arguments for the
existence of God work in a vacuum any
more than any other
philosophical doctrines ideas arguments
do I think there's always a lot of
background stuff going on and I I'm okay
with that you know
Kahan would you have a hegallian take on
AI
in terms of what we can know and not
know with this object
I mean I'm not a hegelian I know that
people might think that I am because I
do the half hour Hegel project and I
teach Hegel occasionally but I don't
always approach things like saying well
what would Hegel say about that I mean I
would say
if you want to get a good take on that
sort of thing
read Aleister McIntyre's essays Hegel on
skulls and faces which has to do with
the phrenology
um you know McIntyre was quite
influenced by Hegel and hegelians
and he edited a volume you know Hegel uh
I think it's selected essays and in that
I think he rightly reconstructs Hegel
with the the phrenology and uh
physiognomy section is saying these
attempts to reduce things for the human
down to you know as Hegel says Spirit
becomes a bone but down to what we would
nowadays call algorithms or you know
decision procedures or stuff like that
anytime that you try to do that genuine
human intelligence resists that and
undermines and unsubverts that
and I think that AI is at least unless
it evolves in in completely different
ways that are basically science fiction
and not anything grounded in where it
currently is AI is always going to be
you know a number of steps behind the
genuinely human
um
so you know there's always going to be a
lot of things that just can't get I mean
thinking about how we program values in
I know that Tech Bros are very
optimistic about this but when you look
at their Endeavors and the models that
they're using they're so primitive that
they don't capture much of what we think
about in terms of values and moral life
and decision making
and stuff like that so I'm I'm pretty
you know AIS can do a lot of cool stuff
it's fun to like have a you know
personal assistant you know we could say
Hey Siri and then Siri can regurgitate
some stuff that she finds on the web or
even make some pre-programmed jokes or
stuff like that but uh and chat GPT is
fun to play around with I haven't tried
Bard yet but I'll be trying that pretty
soon
but they don't seem to be particularly
bright and they're certainly not careful
and they make up stuff and can't figure
out when they've made mistakes
themselves you know the the issue is US
thinking that AI is more like you know
human beings and more intelligent than
it actually is but that's that's on us
that's our projection right so I mean
could you look at that in hegelian way I
guess you could
um
I don't know why you would necessarily
want to look at it using Hegel but
all right uh Sunny has a technical
question here what software and device
do you use to edit and record your
YouTube videos it's impressive to me how
consistent your channel and catalog of
videos are formatted all organized so
um
I use a Hero GoPro as my camera now
before that I used a set of flip cams uh
there used to be a company called flip
and then I don't remember who the other
ones were but I used them until they
basically broke down
um occasionally you know like for shorts
taking pictures on or taking videos on
my phone but
for the most part I'm using that Hero
GoPro and I've got like cheap stuff I
bought from Amazon for lighting and
tripod and you know the more expensive
thing is really that chalkboard upstairs
which I think we paid 400 or 500 for
you know uh 10 years ago massively uh
useful investment given all the the
videos I've gotten out of it
and then I use
um
Apple iMovie you know which is a very
rudimentary program but does the stuff I
needed to do and we have it on a 2000 I
think 2014
iMac uh so you know it's kind of on its
last legs it's gonna have to be replaced
before too long
and that's that's what I've done almost
all the video editing
um a few I've done on on laptops but
generally I um you know doing it on on
my big desktop upstairs and it's it's
that simple and straightforward you know
my stuff is pretty low Tech pretty low
production because I'm not a video guy
you know video editing Guy and
um
if you got good content people
and some people will complain about
anything right oh the sound isn't good
this guy has an accent you know uh why
did you talk about this instead of that
you know you're always going to get that
but
for the most part
if you've got good content like you know
what you're talking about you can talk
to an audience like I'm doing here in
ways that aren't you know dumbing things
down and at the same time are
understandable people like that and
they'll get something out of it so
that's that's basically uh all there is
to it I suppose right
uh Sean on a more practical level what's
your number one language learning tip I
I don't think I have any I mean I I've
often said this the ways in which I
learn languages are rather eccentric and
don't map on well to the ways other
people tend to learn languages you know
like when I was learning
Greek and Latin I was learning them as
like systems that were developing over
time and and I would I would frame the
stuff that most people just memorize
within that like I had to learn the
forms of a verb I wanted to know why the
linguistic
um shifts are taking place the
equivalent in Greek of say
um louding in German you know that sort
of stuff I don't think is real helpful
for other people so you know the only
other the one thing I could say is if
you want to learn a language you got to
put in time you know and this is less of
a tip and more of a like
you know you just have to do this uh you
want to learn a language find yourself
an hour each day where you're going to
work on that language and
when you're like standing in a line you
know run through stuff in your head
those are those are things that can be
helpful so
all right
um hot gal Jolene what do you think of
how German idealists philosophers like
Hegel and shelling thought of the
scientific developments of their time
specifically thinking of shelling's
lectures on chemistry I've never read
shelling's lectures on chemistry I
haven't read much shelling uh at all and
much of what I read was way way back in
in grad school so I'm not a good person
to ask about shelling
there is quite a bit of interest in him
these days which is kind of cool to see
um I can talk about hegel's views on
science when Hegel is criticizing like
overreach on the part of science like we
just talked about you know the
phrenology section I think a lot of that
is applicable to a lot of what people
call Neuroscience today some of which is
really good solid science some of which
is like the the worst pseudoscience uh
you know out there and then there's
everything in between uh I think when
he's being critical of the Sciences
Hegel can be quite insightful I think
his attempt to try to conceptualize
natural science is just a non-starter
and I I wouldn't waste your time with it
given that you can spend your time on
other stuff when it comes to the social
sciences
um you know a lot of what Hagel has to
say is kind of outmoded and outdated but
some of it is is quite still interesting
and suggestive right
um Ollie says new to philosophy started
with the stoics and had gotten enormous
benefits I also watch your videos what
do you think I should invest into next
that'll be worthwhile benefits
I mean if you're if you're looking at
philosophies as ways of life why not
stick around in ancient philosophy and
you know read some platonic dialogues I
mean if you like the stoics they're
inspired by Socrates you get to know
Socrates in significant part through
platonic dialogues also through xenophon
um and the stoics you know as you well
know are also responding to plateness of
their time so I would read Plato's
dialogues and then look at the rest of
the you know bits and pieces of the
platonic tradition like Plutarch or the
later uh plateness that we call
neoplatonus
um definitely want to read Aristotle you
definitely want to you know read what we
have of the epicureans I mean that will
all keep you quite busy for for a while
so
all right Christian who would win a
fight Kafka or Kierkegaard my money is
on Kierkegaard but Kafka could have a
lot of pent-up rage
yeah it's funny I mean having pent
uprage doesn't mean you're going to be a
good fighter I've seen plenty of that
like back when I was younger and you
know Middle School and High School in
the Army and college
um just having rage and throwing punches
doesn't mean that you're not going to
get your ass kicked
um
I don't know why they would want to
fight with each other
um and I don't think that Kafka had a
lot of pent-up rage I think that that
Kafka was is rightly described as
alienated but I don't see rage coming
through in his his works or letters
um any more than in kierkegaards I see
very insightful
uh troubled
men who are you know
in the case of Kafka working jobs in the
case of Kierkegaard able to you know uh
support himself basically through what
he he had access to in his his writing
so
um all right uh
Eric any tips on how to approach fiction
let's say movies or novels and how to
really grasp what's going on and
possibly analyze them there's like a
million ways to analyze fiction and
movies and novels all sorts of
approaches I mean if you just type in
literary criticism and like look at some
encyclopedia entries on that it'll give
you some idea of the depth of or the
range of different theories and
approaches I I guess if you want to
do something like that if you want to
apply a theory to
analyze
cultural products let's call them
you you got to know that theory don't
you so I mean there's some sloppy stuff
out there in film stuff where lacan was
applied you know uh using the mirror
stage but getting that essay and its
content Wrong by malvey and it was kind
of the rage I would actually like uh you
know I mean think about let's start with
Plato right so Plato has a lot to say
about
um poetry and mimesis and storytelling
and stuff like that how would you how
would you analyze
um a TV show like Law and Order for
example the preeminent
cop world show that's been running for
you know decades and has all sorts of
series to it how would you how would you
Analyze That in terms of what Plato has
to say in the Republic not just the
allegory the cave but particularly book
10. I mean that would be one of like
thousands of approaches that you could
take so you know my tip would be
um find some theoretical basis that's
nice and robust
and then play around with that and you
might also look at what the fiction
producers themselves have to say you
know like if you're analyzing Philip K
dick and you're not both looking at his
exegesis which is Philip K Dick's own
Reflections on his
um experiences and projects and some of
his correspondence or interviews about
things you're cutting yourself off from
a really valuable resource that could
help you understand that right
all right uh Zach got accepted to
present at a conference over anger and
uh uh so just skipped a little bit there
we go anger and Injustice responding to
Maisha Cherry if you have any thoughts
or teach this let me know some
directions you would take it I mean
Cherry is responding in part to people
like Nussbaum who are
um
saying that there really isn't any
positive scope for anger in fighting
against
Injustice and you know the other thing
is Cherry is explicitly situating
herself
in what she calls a lordian
perspective coming from audre Lorde and
her really great essay the uses of anger
so I would I would focus I mean are you
like criticizing uh
uh Cherry are you reinterpreting her and
going farther
um whatever is the case engaging with
cherry also means engaging with Lord
uh then you know some other thinkers as
well and I I would say one Avenue for
this is thinking about the scope of it
can can the things that you know Cherry
is arguing in terms of fighting against
racial Injustice and for racial Justice
can this be applied to all other sorts
of
striving for justice that would be an
interesting uh way to go right
Stephen Warren says
any thoughts on the delusion critique of
negativity or dairy does understanding
of negativity
um no I don't have any thoughts on those
in part because I don't know what the
delusion critique of negativity means I
mean are you talking about like hegelian
understandings of the negative that
negativity is a very very very broad
term right and it means a lot of
different things so I don't I don't know
enough about either of those in relation
to this vast swath of stuff that you
could say begins with the sophist
Plato's sophist onward to say much about
that
uh Max
do you have any assumptions I should
keep in mind when reading CS purse
it's hard for me to make too many heads
or tails out of his fallibalism and
cynicism
um yeah I mean
I don't know that there is like a
Persian
full system right out there
That You Could reconstruct from his
stuff
um
he certainly is somebody who loves
making distinctions coining terms he's
kind of Scholastic in that way right
although he he aims to expand things
Beyond
um the philosophy available at his time
by taking into account you know things
like semiotics so yeah I don't know that
I have anything uh that would be a
helpful
assumption to keep in mind other than
you know purse is trying to work at
something and finding sometimes
difficulties articulating it
uh I'm not sure how to pronounce this uh
see for sure any thoughts on batai some
logica I haven't read it
um so no thoughts on that Sonny I'm
nearing graduation without much real
world practical experience and have tons
of time spent in Fe education and feel
my scales for judging are a bit in
Balance white what might philosophy
offer a person trying to make sense of
way up and consider their Myriad
interest motives dreams which can appear
to bifurcate an odd or conflicting
directions
well I don't know what Fe education is
um and I don't know whether you're
talking about graduating from
undergraduate or graduate you know
degrees but what can philosophy do so
you know
it reminds me of something that that
Cicero says in
on duties
where he's he's saying you know penetius
wrote a great book on duties and I'm
going to like give you the gist of it
and add some stuff of my own but I think
that panatius also didn't talk quite
enough about
um some issues that that we would
normally discuss in philosophy
um
so
we're not generally worrying about
just the good and the bad
we're more worried about the better and
the worse right so you graduate and you
gotta like figure out what your
priorities are and your priorities are
probably going to be a bit different
right now than they are 10 years from
now 20 years from now and it's okay for
them to change so you have to determine
what really matters to you what you
value and then think about as means and
reasoning how you're going to pursue
that how you're going to
get yourself there given that you're
living in a world that is is permeated
by what ancient philosophers called
Fortuna chance you know so it's not like
a fair system where you put in your
input and then the world rewards you but
you can you know you can't have some
influence over it so obviously if you
want to apply for a job that uh requires
you to um do you know significant work
um
with languages well you've got to know
languages right so there's all of those
factors as well
um you can't have it all you know I
actually I I
um
did one of those quick takes about that
you you do have to prioritize between
different things and figure out what it
is that you
really want to make Central in your life
right so that's uh I think that's
important
um
Ezra have you done any deep Research
into lesser-known Christian theologians
Gregory Palomas Gregory of nazianus not
those two but yeah I've done plenty of
work in lesser-known Christian
theologians and even done some videos on
them particularly for my anger class you
know I did a whole sequence of videos on
lock tonsillas uh who's who certainly
qualifies as lesser known uh doing all
the work that I did on on the Christian
philosophy debates involved looking at
the people who actually viewed
themselves as Christian philosophers
which would include like tonsillas but
also Clement of Alexandria
um Justin Martyr uh you know Tatian
who's writing against the Greeks
um quite a few others as well
um you know and we can also like think
in terms of well-known Christian
thinkers but who also write texts that
not that many people read so like
Augustine a lot of people read him but
they don't read his treaties he's online
which are very very interesting right so
yeah so I've done a good bit of work
into them and one of the things you
realize also like looking at
um you know ancient philosophies there's
just so much stuff out there that you
can't possibly read all of it you know
uh and Olivia are there any works you
recommend that build on Blown dollar or
would be of great interest to anyone who
enjoys Bloomdale Blondell influenced a
whole slew of thinkers in the 20th
century in French writing and even some
uh people overseas think about Norris
Clark and you know his acknowledgment of
blown down Norris Clark is a very
interesting American Thomas thinker who
um not only you know was thinking in
terms of like Thomas and neoplatonism
but
um also like looked at uh process
philosophy as well but you know yeah I
mean if you like blown Dell you're
probably also going to like Gabrielle
Marcel who certainly acknowledges places
where he thinks you know blondellas got
things right
um there are a number of Thomas
influenced by him like Antonin certiage
a lot of his Works haven't been
translated but he does have a nice short
work called the intellectual life which
is well worth reading
so
um you know and I mentioned Carol votea
the acting person actually mentions
blodendell at certain points as well
um so there's I think there's quite a
few people out there
uh James do you have any thoughts on
martiusen's capabilities approach I
haven't looked at it for a long time so
I don't really have much to say about it
uh it's not something that I'm like a
specialist in you could say
um
Sophie which Greek school of thought
would you say sister was influenced the
most by in his political philosophy
well if you just said philosophy I'd say
of course the academic Skeptics because
he identifies as that
um when it comes to his political
philosophy
Cicero is certainly influenced by
Aristotle and Plato who he sees as being
very close to each other and by the
stoics I don't know that there is a
school that he is most influenced by
you know I'd say it's kind of he's
putting together an amalgam and then
trying to think about
how it applies in the specific situation
that he's in which is quite a bit
different than
you know
Aristotle's time when he had all these
different city-states and then you had
the Macedonian hegemony you know
uh Ethel do you think it's completely
necessary to read philosophy in
chronological order especially with a
heavy interest in phenomenology I think
you can read philosophy any way you want
to there's no necessary about it
um you might find later on that you're
like oh I wish I hadn't skipped over
this person
but if you were going to read philosophy
and chronological order and you were
going to be like really thorough
you probably never get to phenomenology
right there's so much just in ancient
philosophy to occupy you for years and
years and years and years right and then
there's medieval philosophy right I mean
you might get some phenomenology along
the way I often say that like
Aristotle's Nick and McCain ethics I
read is a phenomenology of the moral
life but I'm I'm in the minority on that
uh Lenny Penny what is the difference
between Heidegger's concept of nothing
and starts I'm also confused about their
existential philosophy differs in
general I mean it to be facetious there
is what is the difference between
Heidegger's nothing and starts nothing
nothing there's nothing separating them
I mean
the differences are not things where you
can like bullet point it out or anything
like that you got to read their texts
and see what I would say see what
they're doing with their nothing
Heidegger doesn't think you can
conceptualize the nothing sart doesn't
think you can conceptualize the nothing
so the nothing is not a something that
will sit still and let you categorize it
right
um and you know if you want to see
probably the best
way the best
this set of distinctions between their
philosophy read Heidegger's letter on
humanism
um sart was saying basically
you know that he's taking a lot of his
ideas from Heidegger and Heidegger's
like man you're doing something
different over there and I don't buy
into it so why not go to the master
himself and and see what what he has to
say
um Sophie says love your videos ah glad
um Sonny any side Hobbies or activities
you particularly enjoy so why are you
still playing the banjo yeah I mean I
haven't been playing it as much lately
uh over the last couple months because
I've just been so so busy and every day
at the end of the day I'm I'm worn out
but with Summer coming and not teaching
academic classes I'll certainly get an
opportunity to play more
like taking walks around you know my
city Milwaukee
and taking pictures you've probably seen
a lot of them in social media
I just came back from almost home cat
shelter a little bit earlier today
before I started this we're not going to
adopt new cats but I I do enjoy going in
and giving them some attention and you
know play and love and and uh
hanging out with them and I will
probably be volunteering there from the
summer onward
um
you know we we go to musical
performances quite a lot
um we were really fortunate living here
in in the downtown of Milwaukee where we
have
10 different concert venues and
performance houses and you know places
where we can see live theater just
within you know a mile walk from where
we live some of them much closer
so you know that's that's really it you
know I like to exercise
um don't always get to do it I like to
read a lot
um you know
speculative fiction is part of that so
all right uh
Christian says I used to have a flip
camera when I was 10. absolutely loved
making short films with them yeah I mean
they were inexpensive you could plug
them right into your computer through
that little like dongle thing that it
had you know they were pretty cool
um
Andre says imagine that some
archaeologists found the remaining books
of epictetus's discourses what kind of
topics would we find there what
discussions are lacking in the first
four books that you would like to find
there well you know Epictetus doesn't
talk much about virtue he does it only
at a few points certainly not as much as
Seneca and even Marcus Aurelius or
Cicero Epictetus talks much more instead
of other qualities and about you know
the fundamental distinction the the
prolapses between what what's up to us
what's not up to us the proy racist and
stuff like that so maybe there'd be more
analysis of the virtues I'd love to see
more little conversations and stories
about Epictetus ran into a guy and the
guy said I have this problem and
Epictetus said hey here's how you should
look at it
um maybe more discussions of the
emotions Beyond
um
fear and anger and anxiety and
concerns over solitude but I don't we
don't really know what's in these other
books that were lost so I don't know
um
all right
maximum do you think kierkegaard's
pseudonymical
pseudonymical works uh different much
compared to his Works under his own name
philosophically speaking
um you know yes and no they're from
different
points of view they're supposed to be
representing different things
but you know I think when we're reading
them we we do view a lot of that as well
here's Kierkegaard giving us his take
not like it's just a completely
different character
and if there is a kierkega guardian
system to discern certainly you know
these books that he wrote Under other
names are are also part of that so
all right
um
Bob Ken says I want to ask what are your
thoughts on gwc Bald I want to read them
for myself but also would love to hear
what you would say
I've never heard of them so
I I don't know what um
whether he's good or bad or any of these
sorts of things uh by the way where do
you get your t-shirts they're cool
um you know we order band T-shirts every
once in a while sometimes we'll buy one
at a concert
um
for my 50th birthday a couple years ago
I put a bunch of band T-shirts into an
Amazon wish list and quite a few people
bought them for me including this one
the rainbow shirt that I have on right
now so I you know I wear band shirts
quite a lot
um
some of them are getting kind of worn
out
like my KISS Army shirt it's got a lot
of holes in it because Sassy the cat
before she died would you know climb all
over me and clawed to me my Judas Priest
uh British steel shirt pretty worse for
wear it's gonna probably have to be
retired before too long my Raven
Kickstarter shirt uh is like that as
well
all right
um Andre much has been said about the
negative impact of chat GPT and the like
in education how do you see tools like
this being used in helpful ways in the
context of education and learning well
it's going to take a lot of work
um
I mean I'm gonna be thinking about this
over the summer
um
how to incorporate chat GPT specifically
or maybe maybe others as well
into
writing projects but you got to be so so
careful
with it because chat GPT will make up
sources sources that don't exist and so
basically everything that chat GPT tells
you
you probably need to corroborate with
some other source right the other
problem with chat GPT and I think this
could be useful for some students
is that
the writing that it does produce it
sounds good it's glib it's stylistically
decent right syntactically it's correct
but
it's often
not very good writing it's stereotypical
it uses a lot of
things that are almost cliches like when
you ask it a bunch of questions and you
see it saying basically the same thing
over and over again you're like this is
the equivalent of somebody who's
memorized like a sales pitch and doesn't
fully understand what the words mean so
I think chat GPT could be used in
um
classroom settings for students to think
about the limitations of chat GPT you
know and I'm actually uh probably going
to design some assignments and
activities around that sort of thing
we also want to avoid you know people
thinking that it's the next great tool
for plagiarism
but that's a broader topic that that I'm
also going to do some work on over the
summer
all right
um I just skipped a little bit
Christian mcdepressed thanks so much
that actually helped out my
understanding of Kafka I've been trying
to get into him have a tough time yeah
you know Kafka
um he's somebody I really enjoy and have
since
um
since I was in college
I mean we all read the metamorphosis in
high school I think
and I didn't really I didn't enjoy it
that much at the time but then I started
reading some of his other stories I
think somebody had recommended I should
read
uh the trial and I started reading that
and I was like holy crap is this
interesting stuff you know uh especially
that vision of like the Law Courts being
in everybody's attics and that was uh
quite stunning and then I started
reading my way through a lot of his
other short stories and and uh you know
I read
um the castle as well and uh so he's
he's quite a good good person to to work
with I think
uh
um max says do you have any big tips on
dealing with or figuring out what big
things you want to do after graduating
college
aside from getting a job within your
major
uh
well times are tough right so unless
you're independently wealthy or you have
a great support network your options are
going to be somewhat Limited
and so I think this thing we talked
about a little bit earlier figuring out
what to prioritize based on what you
think at the time you really want what
you really desire
is going to be key so you know thinking
about like where do you where do you
actually want to live
if you're just getting out of college
um You probably don't have a ton of
resources but you could start thinking
about like where do I want to where do I
want to be living 10 years from now do I
want to stay here in this college town
do I want to be in some other state do I
want to be overseas you know and then
start start doing like the backward
design thinking okay if I've got this
goal what do I actually need to do what
are the steps to get me to that goal you
know and then you could also think to
yourself
if this goal doesn't make it could those
steps also be helpful for getting me
somewhere else you know
um
so that I don't know that might that
might be helpful
uh Marco how important do you think
Machiavelli has been in the history of
political thought I mean he's considered
a very important thinker I think most
people who talk about Machiavelli
more or less get him wrong because they
think he's just saying uh be as ruthless
as possible that that's not actually a
winning strategy for Machiavelli and
Machiavelli has some very interesting
class discussions or discussions about
class Dynamics in the prince uh where he
says you you always have to watch those
Rich bastards because they're always
going to be trying to oppress everybody
else you know he's not like saying yeah
let's celebrate the rich you know let
them do whatever the hell they want he's
like you need to Reign those people in
you know so I think there's a lot of
inattentive readings of Machiavelli and
then you know Machiavelli didn't just
write the prince he also wrote other
works as well where he's a you know bit
less about be ruthless you know and more
about you know if you want a functioning
Society here's the things you have to do
um
so you know I think he's he's pretty
important
um
so black prairie
I was curious if you have any arguments
against Pop Culture nihilism biological
determinism
a friend of mine used to be really into
those years ago and I found it draining
on my end I also find this to be
extremely common in social media
I recently wrote a paper on why study
philosophy and wrote a section against
nihilism I mean
depends on what you mean by nihilism if
nihilism is just like being
contradictory and negating things that's
not what traditionally has been called
nihilism that's just somebody like
putting on errors like the person who
takes cold showers and says that they're
a stoic you know to really be a nihilist
means to be committed to the idea that
you know there there really are no
lasting stable found you know with
foundations values out there that we can
we can trust in anything can be
undermined and
um you know where their resources
against it I mean a lot of the people
who talk about nihilism Nietzsche not a
nihilist right nature thinks that
nihilism is the problem of the 20th
century that has to be diagnosed and
dealt with
um Camus
barely an absurdist really I mean he
really is he does fit into the
existentialist Spectrum not a nihilist
you know I mean look at the the rebel
um even people who have nihilist
characters like Dostoevsky or Georgina
one of the earliest uh things in that
they're not always presented as like
this is the way that we have to go you
know and there's there's contradictions
within it you know
let's see if somebody can actually live
out their life as a mealist or if
they're just you know like you call it
pop culture you know
um
now biological determinism that's a
whole different thing I mean there's no
necessary connection between that and
nihilism or really any other
um
ideology
I mean I why do you even take your
friend putting this stuff stuff out
there seriously when it comes to
biological determinism
where the hell is the evidence for that
you know a few studies that get like
done on a few things and then blown way
out of proportion
I think that people who wholeheartedly
believe in something like biological
determinism
you you have to be like well why the
hell would you believe in that
what's you know
what's making you buy into something
that there isn't much evidence for at
all
um isn't that a kind of flaw on your
part I mean I I I just wouldn't hang out
with somebody like that very much myself
so
all right uh Ibraham uh
uh on average how many hours per day
have you spent reading philosophy
I'm overwhelmed by how much good books
there are to read but need my reading to
be effective so you know I wouldn't
worry enough a lot about your reading
being effective until you've actually
like done a lot of reading and then you
can like look back on it and ask
effective and effective for what
effective is a relative term there's no
such thing as like effectivity per se
um it varies I mean a lot of the reading
that I'm doing is often rereading
rereading so I can do videos so I can
like present to students or things like
that work with my clients
um
you know I'm
I don't know anywhere from zero hours a
day to on a really great day where I
don't have a ton of other things to do
maybe six hours per day
and so I don't know what the average is
because I I don't worry about charting
that sort of thing
um I mean I think it's better just to
say let's try to get in as much reading
as we can
rather than shoot for a particular
number you know
um
all right let me uh
move on to some people that haven't uh
had the chance to get a question
answered Luke mockery I found the series
on like tancius and Seneca and anger
very useful I got three lessons out of
them for various groups I teach
occasionally is there anybody who talks
about forgiveness and anger like
hundreds of people talk about
forgiveness and anger including uh
Aristotle you know and the nick of
McCann ethics and and the the rhetoric
um and then many many other people after
that so there's lots and lots and lots
of philosophers who talk about anger and
how we ought to to deal with it all the
way down to the present time you know
uh RT Whitby says what is your opinion
of the connection between wokism and
neo-marxism and the connection of
thinkers like Herbert Marcus I think
that's all complete gibberish nonsense
um I don't take anybody seriously who
uses the word woke pejoratively to me
that's always a sign that somebody's
brain is rotted you know it's funny
because like the uh the conservatives
talking who aren't really conservatives
anymore they're they're like weird way
off in in la la land people they talk
about woke mind virus and that perfectly
describes mind virus this antipathy
against the term woke which you know 10
years ago was PC and it's always going
to be some right
um
post-modern Marxism cultural bolshevism
neo-marxism these are all just sloppy
terms that people use for I don't like
that over there right
and who reads Marcus these days who's
read Marcus for
you know years and years and years I
mean the it's funny to see the
caricatures that people who are like
critical of Marxism or post-modernism or
the woke or PC or pick whatever their
cancel culture whatever the flavor of
the day is
they're always like there's such shitty
historians of ideas and they can't even
like do it well in the present like if
you want to know where somebody's
getting their ideas from
read the people you know who the hell's
talking about Marcus these days you know
not many uh except for the the people
who make a living coming up with these
narratives about woke ISM and
how you know we have to fight the
culture war against them I mean it's
really such a shame that there are so
few
actual what used to be conservatives
left and so many people on the right are
just these rotten brain weirdos who you
know are fortunate enough to have
Facebook groups and you know other sites
where they can get together with their
other fellow crazy weirdos and I wish
they would all just like get the hell
out of the rest of our way so we can
like produce a workable Society where
we're not going to get shot by some you
know
rageaholic who got got himself some guns
or you know people who are afraid to
wear a mask and afraid to look like
they're in fear and blah blah blah blah
blah so that's my opinion
all right
um
Pat hope you're having a good Holy
Saturday which of Christ's words from
the cross are the most impactful or
profound to you
you know he didn't say a hell of a lot
from the cross
um and that isn't where I would put my
attention uh my standard response
basically that I've had for years and
years and years to people who are like
well what's Christianity about or what
are what's the most important of Jesus's
teachings is
Sermon on the Mount I mean he's actually
like
speaking to the crowds setting out the
reinterpretation of the law
um making a whole bunch of things super
clear and if you can't live up to that I
don't want to hear about anything else I
don't want to hear about the Book of
Revelations I don't want to hear about
you know uh Leviticus and a man shall
not lie with a man if you can't do the
stuff that Jesus is actually straight
out saying here's what I want you to do
in these definitive teachings
you're not a Christian whatever crosses
you might wear or whatever stuff you
might say that is the definitive Central
teaching that and the other stuff that
we find in the gospels by the time that
he's on the cross he's been teaching for
for years to his his disciples that's
the super important stuff I would say
that The Sermon on the Mount is even
more important than the inauguration you
know of sacraments at the the Last
Supper that's
more important you know so
all right
um
Aeron is it possible to get into grad
school and philosophy with zero
philosophy background and undergrad any
tips
uh yeah don't try that
I mean
is it possible to get in with zero uh
uh background and philosophy in
undergrad
not in any accredited program even when
I was in grad school there were people
who would come in with degrees like say
in literature but they'd also studied
some philosophy and then they would have
to take remedial classes if they were
accepted right uh odds are you're not
going to get accepted because there's
other people applying who actually have
bachelor's degrees in philosophy and
why why would a school want to take
a person who doesn't have any background
in that discipline and put aside
philosophy why would why would a history
program want to let somebody in who's
got no background in history why would a
rhetoric composition program want to let
somebody in whose degree is in
mechanical engineering and
you gotta um
you gotta find some way to like convince
them that you would be a viable
candidate first right
um James
I find that most discussions of Hobbes
as Leviathan are limited to books one
and two do you think books three and
four are important to read too I don't
um it's all this weird crazy theological
stuff there's a good reason why the only
people who pay attention to that stuff
are Hobbs Scholars and actually even
them a lot of them don't worry about
what's going on in book three and four
the real meat is in books one and two
the other stuff is just Hobbs
doing his his weird theological you know
arguments and investigations that nobody
I think ever bought into you know so
I wouldn't I wouldn't worry about that
um
Pat says my biggest concern with chat
GPT is how it's propped up as a neutral
objective tool kind of part of the
problem of the Zeitgeist epistemate
being solidified in every question
a problem I haven't met too many people
who who view chat GPT as
just an objective tool
um those of us who've played around it
seems probably there's more people at
least in education on the pessimistic
side there's a lot of like uh Chicken
Little the sky is falling stuff oh this
is going to destroy you know our ability
to ever tell if a student is cheating or
not I don't think so
um
I think the biggest danger is people
being too optimistic about it so it's
not a neutral thing it's the people who
are like this is the wave of the future
we're going to use this but
you know it's it's uh it turns out to be
so disappointing in its actual practice
that I I I just I'm having a harder time
viewing it as really
that
um
that worrisome I will put in a a plug
though uh so our latest episode of the
wisdom for Life show which is airing
today uh later on in the afternoon on
wxrw which you can find online and
listen to online is about large language
models and artificial intelligence and
you know we even did some like playing
around like we asked chat GPT to tell us
about ourselves you know me and Dan the
host and about the wisdom for Life show
and it couldn't couldn't come up with
anything really it had to like I had to
have it speculate about what wisdom for
Life Show Must might be about so
all right uh
Bruno actually says I'm reading books
three and four of the Leviathan were
these texts influential
not influential at all as far as I can
tell I mean it looks like historically
um people who engaged with Hobbes
Leviathan were mostly interested in
books one and two
um I mean it's interesting to read
through three and four maybe everybody
should do it you know if they want to
like seriously study Hobbs you should do
it once in your life but then you
probably don't need to do it afterwards
you know so
all right uh info boy I think you heard
your say heard you say that you're into
Duran Duran how did you get into them
have you seen them live they were the
first band I got into as a teen I didn't
see them live until 04 and they were
still great yeah we saw them live I saw
them for the very first time live last
fall last summer last fall down in
Chicago
uh at the United Center
um and they were there with uh Sheikh
who were really good too that was the
opening band
um
so it was a lot of fun and interestingly
so we were watching on our TV Austin
City Limits in the spring and we saw
Duran Duran performing and we were like
holy crap those guys are old but they
you know they still got it you know uh
we we should go see them right so so we
did that and how did I get into Duran
Duran so you know they were a big band
when I was in Middle School and High
School
and when I was in Middle School you know
I I wasn't I mean I was into some metal
stuff but I didn't I didn't know it as
heavy metal at the time like you know I
like to kiss and I liked AC DC and you
know Def Leppard and a few other bands
but I I didn't know it as you know the
the genre and you know I'd kind of just
listened to what was on the radio and
Duran Duran was on the radio a lot and I
I like their stuff you know and that's
when like Rio had come out
um I found their songs interesting
imaginative I wasn't a big dancer so I
didn't worry about that but I kind of
grooved to their stuff and then you know
they kind of fell by the wayside
by the time I was between middle school
and high school I was like getting I was
like Galloping into heavy metal like I
knew a lot of other kids who uh had
stuff and were like swapping tapes and
stuff like that so it was all like you
know harder and harder stuff and you
know it was a great time to like be
experiencing that so all the softer
stuff the pop stuff kind of fell to the
side and then
um
it was 1994.
and no 1993.
yeah it was 1993 and I was working
security at my college and they had a TV
in the student center that always was uh
put to MTV
and I saw this video for Come Undone and
I was like
wow this is uh this is great stuff
I think I'll get myself that um that
tape and I actually I went to the the
music store and I got myself the tape of
the
um uh the wedding album that no it
wasn't the wedding album what was Come
Undone it was the one before the the
wedding album I think right and I also
got Stone Temple Pilots core and I would
listen to them you know uh on my I had
like a a boom box I'd listen to them on
and a portable cassette recorder and uh
then I got more into Duran Duran I
started like listening to them some more
and it's funny because uh there's a
friend of mine from grad school who she
said she could tell that I was a decent
guy because she she came into my room
one time and she's like looking at my
stack of CDs and she's you know it's
mostly harder heavier stuff you know
metal grunge that that sort of thing and
then there's Duran Duran and she's like
you're in the Duran Duran and I was like
yeah I love Dorian Duran and she's like
I wouldn't have thought that about you
and I was like well you know
man of many qualities so
all right
um
Bader if you're only allowed five books
stuck on an island which would you pick
did a video about that years ago
um I did that for philosophical works I
I don't know that I'd be able to pick a
set
um I'd have to think about that a lot
more Benjamin love God and love
neighbors yourself sums it all up it
sums it up but it's not sufficient you
need a lot more guidance than that and
that's why Jesus provides a lot more
guidance he doesn't just say well here's
your two principles he gives you a whole
set that you can find in Matthew and
then plenty more and and Luke as well
and and John right
um
Alan the most fascinating course I've
ever attended was a dialogue between
Kant and Carl Schmidt
well
that's interesting uh I don't know that
I would have found that fascinating but
you know Leslie met a soul mate he's gay
and we're Catholic could he explain and
justify your views on gay marriage and
parenting how can gay marriage be fully
justifiable by expressing the image of
godhead
I don't really give a about gay
marriage or stuff like that you know I
think that there's way too many people
that are obsessed just obsessed with
sexual morality but totally ignore the
parts about don't commit adultery don't
be lustful they're all you know worried
about identity and gay marriage and
things like that and they should be much
more focused on thinking about what is
the purpose of of you know having sex in
the first place right is and and having
relationships is it just for pleasure is
it just for you know production of
children is it supposed to Foster
intimacy you know I think that the whole
idea of like some things being
intrinsically disordered down the line
we're going to look at that we're going
to be like what the hell were they
thinking you know what what weird biases
did they have at the time
um
and I think that's you know for me
that's that's the way to to go with this
this sort of thing
um I mean every human being if we
actually believe that we are made in the
image or after the image of God every
single human being is by being human
being and we're all messed up images and
I think the people who are again
obsessed over sexuality that's often how
they're messed up right
um so that's probably enough about that
a spa bet on chat GPT do you think that
in a conscient sense this kind of AI is
only limited to making statements that
are analytic based on what we give it
rather than synthetic yeah if you want
to change the conscient sense to mean
that which is not what Kant means by it
um
I mean
that's that's fine I don't see any any
utility in wanting to bring in that
terminology
um chat GPT can really only work off of
the data sets that it has and there's a
larger thing for AIS so it depends on
what your data set is if we're talking
about artwork it's the stuff that it's
able to draw on right
um if it's certain AIS it might like
crawl the internet and use a whole bunch
of stuff and like update things in real
time it all depends on what we're
actually supplying it with and so we
should be you know thinking about that
it doesn't seem I mean it is
synthesizing the material that it's
being given it is producing interesting
new stuff
but really not that interesting
unfortunately so
all right
um Nolan loved the rainbow shirt yeah
that's a great band
um
I saw somebody posting today in Twitter
uh about uh Richie Blackmore like
leaving deep purple and founding rainbow
and recruiting Ronnie James Dio
and yeah he did recruit Ronnie James
deal but he recruited Ronnie James Dio's
entire band elf and then except for the
guitarist and then fired all the rest of
them except for Ronnie James Dio which
is kind of a dick move but that's
typical Richie Blackmore you know the
scowling soloist
um those first three albums are just
amazing you know it's funny too like
when people are like you know some every
once in a while people buy into this
this narrative that Rob Halford likes to
trot out and that a bunch of like
metal heads who came into it late
uncritically accepted that while there
was Black Sabbath and they were like in
the wilderness and nobody else was
really doing heavy metal in the 1970s
until Judas Priest came along you know
like
come on you never heard a rainbow you
know uh they were they were massive they
were you know the face of metal as was
UFO as was Deep Purple as was Montrose
as we could go down the line uh and if
there's kind of a self-serving narrative
that Rob Halford will sometimes put out
all right the procoped on how important
is the ethics of roles in Epictetus
massively important right it's uh
brought up over and over and over again
um
I think it's better not to call it the
ethics of roles but to say that roles
play a major role in epictetus's ethics
right so it's not that Epictetus just
has a role ethic and I think that that
Brian Johnson's book the role ethics of
Epictetus which appears to have been his
dissertation going by the way it's
structured has done some disservice
um in pushing that
giving people the impression that that's
the main thing that's going on
I think there's a you know a
comprehensive ethics in Epictetus and
roles play a really significant part of
that Hamilton roles play a significant
role
um Nolan says would you happen to have
any suggestions for the philosophy
behind entropy or disorder in systems
I'm currently studying the physics but
would like to ex the physics or physics
but would like to explore philosophy
um
that's a good question
I mean there's a lot of like Reflections
on entropy
in some sci-fi authors like Philip K
dick right
um where it's it's a theme that comes up
in many of his works but
entropy understood as such in terms of
like the universe slowly getting to the
state where less and less
information or or energy is available
um I don't you know I don't know maybe
there's there's people out there that
are talking about that right now but
not a lot comes to mind for me I mean a
lot I think a lot of people typically
would conceptualize this more through
like meaning or death or
stuff like that
I mean with a lot of the people who we
read didn't have that available as a
concept right so
um
Brock says reading through ficta Hegel I
find their discussions on
self-consciousness fascinating
what philosophers do you find most
intriguing on this thoughts on
Consciousness transcending death
well I think those are two different
things right so self-consciousness and
then Consciousness transcending physical
death those are like two big areas and I
would say that you know the the
importance of
other people
and our conception of ourself our
understanding of ourself is already
there in you know ancient philosophy in
you know Plato and Aristotle the
Thematic drive that we have this the
striving for recognition also the
importance of friendship and
relationships
um
so it's you know it's not a theme that's
unique and there's all different ways in
which it takes shape
uh I mean it gets a little bit more
complicated once you got like a personal
God in the picture doesn't it right
um but there's all there's lots and lots
of very interesting
um ideas with this you know one of the
things that I did some writing on a long
time ago was
um
Anselm in his letters and how he will
talk about like having the image of a
person within oneself and relating
oneself to that image like say loving
that person or thinking about what they
would say but that's already there
interestingly in Seneca
who was read in the monasteries because
they thought it was like a a crypto
Christian uh and they they copied out
his texts so you know Hegel and ficta
way way down the line there's all of
this other stuff happening leading
leading up to that you know
um
so yeah there's there's a there's a lot
of
people you could you could read uh
talking about them then after Hegel
right this becomes a big theme in 20th
century
um Continental philosophy doesn't it so
you know sart has his take and Marcel is
his take and the buar and lacan and all
these all these people talking about
self-consciousness existing in relation
to others so yeah all right um
Gilgamesh do you think nominalism is a
plausible position or true depends on
who's nominalism we're talking about I
don't think there's any such thing as a
generic nominalism because that would be
sort of a contradiction in itself
wouldn't it so whose nominalism are we
are we talking about uh you know and
then we can say do we find it plausible
James are there any strands of
philosophical thought that piss you off
I personally think metaethics is mostly
BS
um
pissed me off probably no I I would say
that there's there's stuff that people
really seem to obsess about that I just
don't think there's that much value
there
um but it doesn't tick me off so much
um on metaethics
recognizing that there is a division in
academic philosophy and itself
presentation that calls itself
meta-ethics I think that substantively
there's really no such thing as meta
ethics in any real sense where there's
like you know ethics ethics down here
whatever you want to call it you know
prescriptive ethics descriptive ethics
and then meta ethics up on top because
what people call Meta ethics means like
theorizing about this other stuff and
that is done by people who they
typically place at that bottom level
Kant talks about all sorts of other
ethical
perspectives in say the groundwork like
in part three right that's strictly
speaking metaethics but it's part of
it's coming out of his ethics the
utilitarians reflecting on other ethics
is that meta ethics is that substantive
ethics right
um and then the things that are called
meta-ethics typically have as Aleister
McIntyre has pointed out you know for
example for emotivism they like fall
back into regular ethics if you're a
meta-ethical uh emotivist well you're
going to behave in certain ways and
you're gonna tell people to do certain
things so I don't think that the
distinction really holds up all that
well and I find people who claim that it
it does a little pretentious or
misguided you know
all right
um
info voice
is a pejorative inevitable pushback it's
sad when people of Our Generation who
were Progressive once now act like their
time was when some maximal limit to it
was reached yeah I mean if you if you
find yourself having to like lie to
yourself about what other people are
saying or doing and you know raise all
sorts of crazy fears that are coming to
you from questionable media sources
that's a shitty life you know the life
of the anti-woke is
often pretty
pathetic in a lot of respects
um and I think a lot of these people
would do well to like you know as they
say touch grass get away from the
internet and away from their ideas and
like try to think about what it was like
to be a decent person who actually cared
about social problems and other people
and not all the crap that's being fed to
them
um you know by say Fox News or whatever
other sources are more more radical than
that and what all their weirdo friends
think
um it's not a it's not a good way to
live you know it's kind of a truncated
human life
um
all right
Elijah says given lutherans exclude
action from their theology Orthodox
exclude speculation and reformers
exclude ontology is it reasonable to
relate these to hysteria perversion and
obsession
nope I mean that is like the most
sweeping armchair theologizing I've seen
in a long time
and uh
I wouldn't I wouldn't start with any of
those sort of
premises I mean you want to know what
lutherans in the present are like go
talk to lutherans you know you want to
know what Eastern Orthodox were all over
the map by the way are actually like you
got to spend some time with them and see
what they say today you know uh I don't
think that's that's very helpful at all
Jack do you know what I mean of many
materialists who wrote before the 20th
century I already know of Hobbes and the
epicureans and would like to explore
what led people to materialism
originally
uh yeah I mean
Hobbs is a good starting point
um I mean Spinoza is a materialist of
sorts right and by the way Spinoza does
take some things from Hobbes like in his
uh theological political tractatus or
treaties
um I mean mind and and matter or mind
and extension are supposed to be two
attributes of the same ultimate
substance
um for Spinoza I mean there's there's uh
Pierre garcindy right who is himself an
Epicurean
um
he's a contemporary of Hobbes and
Descartes he actually writes some of the
objections to Descartes
meditations on first philosophy
um there's you know there's a lot of
materialists out there not a ton of them
are particularly well known or studied
at present right
so you're going to find a number of them
particularly in the 18th century uh and
then you know once once we get going in
the 19th and 20th Century there's
there's plenty of them as as well
um Prince of cola do you think studying
philosophy can help existential dread or
will it make it worse depends on what
philosophy you're studying and how
you're studying it I mean studying
philosophy means studying particular
philosophers and texts and thinkers and
you know maybe reading other things
about them so if you've got existential
dread
um
reading for example
um might make it worse you know he's so
anti-systematic he's such a skeptic
about so many things
um but it might be helpful for some
other people you know uh reading sart
could be helpful it could be could be
exacerbating that depending on how
you're reading it
um is it acceptable to willingly remain
ignorant to protect one's sanity so long
as you don't harm anyone else
I mean
if you're having to if you're so
bothered by philosophy and existential
dread that you have to know enough about
the philosophy to willingly remain
ignorant about it that seems like an
awful lot of work and psychical energy
that's devoted to that sort of thing and
I don't know you might be better off
um
leaving philosophy behind altogether and
then trying to forget about it or making
your way through it in that case
uh Pat says
if you could remove one philosopher from
the history of philosophy
along with all their influence who would
you pick
I mean I I don't know that I would
um
I guess if we had to choose somebody
whose own thought
has been you know particularly
stultifying
on it you know the adherence of that
thought
um on the whole it would be Iron Rand
right I mean you could say well what
about marks you know it led to all this
this suffering well you know there's an
argument to be made there that Stalin
wasn't really a Marxist or you know all
that sort of stuff that you've
doubtlessed heard many times
um
but you don't find I mean you can find
marxists who are intelligent Humane
people you don't find many followers of
Ein Rand that are and you know you could
also claim you know Marx he's certainly
uh has bad takes on the history of
philosophy well so does I ran I mean if
you're reading Aristotle because you
read Iran and then uh she said Aristotle
was was really great if you rely upon
her as an interpreter of Aristotle you
get Aristotle rug and then she's got all
these you know anti-heroes in philosophy
you know that nature guy is bad Kant is
terrible Plato is horrible you know
um those aren't those aren't good
good takes you could say so I don't know
maybe I would remove her but I don't
know that I would really want to remove
too many people you know
uh Paul says um
I know you do a lot of work in the
history of philosophy are there any
contemporary philosophers still
publishing you particularly enjoy
yeah but a lot of them are doing stuff
in the history of philosophy right
um you know Aleister McIntyre Julia
Annis you know these are these are
people I greatly respect but they are
people who are informed themselves by
the history of philosophy so yeah
there's I'm not somebody who's like
looking for who's the new name who's The
Cutting Edge or something like that
um
and you know frankly there's just so
many people out there would be hard to
stay on top of all the the new people
um
shubham says
can you tell us some resources to gain a
great overall philosophical knowledge
and a short span of time
um probably not I mean
you're not gonna get a great uh
overall philosophical knowledge and a
short span of time you know and and I
think you know this idea of like the
gist basically not in very depth that is
often quite deceiving you can read
um you know representative texts or
secondary sources on somebody and you
could think oh I got it Plato is saying
this
and then when you read more widely
you'll be like oh man I I was wrong
about Plato you know I thought I knew
what he was doing I thought I had the
gist of it but it was actually different
than that so I I would I would try to
avoid that you know
um
I'm gonna have to wrap up soon because I
got to get some lunch before I have
another uh meeting info boy I've heard
it said there's no unambiguous
articulations of something like the
modern Bond the the modern mind-body
problem in ancient philosophy not really
before Descartes sounds dubious to me
but would you agree depends on what you
mean by the problem okay what's the
relationship between mind and body
um there's lots of different takes on
that I mean Aristotle's de animal would
be one of those I'm not sure what you
mean by unambiguous or why Descartes
would be unambiguous but you know the
Fado or the uh other works you know from
ancient philosophy would be ambiguous so
all right uh
Tomas says do you think Hagel could
explain what he had to say in more clear
ways or his philosophy had to be that
complex in its form I'm in love with the
substance of what he says but is writing
tough
I don't know I mean
Hegel seemed to think that the form of
expression was necessary to what he was
doing
you'll see him approaching sometimes the
same topics in different ways depending
on whether it's in the phenomenology or
the two Logics or the philosophy of
right or in various lectures
sometimes it's more clear sometimes it's
less so he wasn't the most clear writer
period in German
um
but you know we do what we can right so
all right let me take one last question
from Max what do you think about looking
up lexicons for Scholastic terminology
Aquinas occasionally uses some technical
terminology in the summer-like formality
um
I would be
I would think the first thing you need
to do is
go back to the Latin and see whether
it's the translator who's used those
terms or whether it's Thomas himself
who's using those terms and then there's
nothing wrong with you know looking up
lexicons
um and trying to figure out what the
terminology means but you also got to be
attentive to the context don't just
think oh I've got it now I can sub it in
there and now I figured out exactly
what's going on
um you know Thomas is like all of us
using language to try to figure things
out and express them sometimes it's
going to be more clear sometimes it'll
be less
um but yeah there's nothing wrong with
using
uh guides or stuff like that just be
always be a little bit you know careful
with how much you rely upon them you
know
so that's a good place to leave off
um so thanks for everybody for questions
comments it's been a nice AMA
um we got uh another event tomorrow if
you're interested in it later on in the
afternoon 3 P.M central time I'm going
to be doing a reading of one of my
favorite short stories uh Jorge Louis
Borges the library at Babel so if you're
interested in that sort of thing maybe
you want to hang out and show up for
that so I will see you all Somewhere In
The Ether and uh I'll talk to all of you
later on